OUR PRAYERS ARE WITH THE TWO
OFFICERS FIGHTING FOR THEIR
LIVES.
POLICE IN THIS COUNTRY ARE UNDER
ATTACK.
CITIES ARE WAR ZONES.
2000 COPS HAVE BEEN LIT ON FIRED
AND PELTED BRICKS AND ROCKS AND
STABBED AND SHOT AND RUN OVER.
SO FAR THIS YEAR 45 POLICE
OFFICERS HAVE BEEN MURDERED IN
THE LINE OF CONSTITUTY.
33 SHOT.
9 WERE VICTIMS OF ASSAULT AND
ONE BEATEN TO DEATH.
-- 8 WERE THE VICTIMS OF AN
AMBUSH.
MORE MONTHS DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE
NOTHING BUT FAN THE FLAMES OF
THIS DESTRUCTIVE RAGE AND DENIED
IT’S HAPPENING.
WE WARNED LIBERAL DEMOCRATS THIS
RHETORIC IS DANGEROUS AND WOULD
NOT END WELL.
THE DNC CONVENTION THEY BARELY
MENTIONED THE VIOLENCE.
INSTEAD DEMOCRATS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WERE ARM IN ARM WITH THE
EFFORT TO DEFUND THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
THEY PREVENTED LOCAL OFFICERS
FROM USING NON-VIOLENT TACTICS
TO DISPERSE CROWDS LIKE TEAR GAS
AND PEPPER SPRAY.
THEY ALREADIED LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO STAND DOWN AS BUILDINGS WERE
TORCHED.
AND POLICE PRECINCTS TAKEN OVER.
THEY JOINED SO CALLED PROTESTS
THAT VILIFY POLICE.
BIDEN SAID POLICE HAVE BECOME
THE ENEMY.
HE WOULD REDIRECT FUNDS AWAY
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT.
KAMALA HARRIS, ARE YOU PROUD OF
YOURSELF TONIGHT YOU?
CHEERED THE IDIOTIC MAYOR OF LOS
ANGELES WHEN MAYOR CUT
150-MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
POLICE FUND.
KAMALA HARRIS AND JOE, LOOK AT
THEIR MANIFESTO.
THEY WANT TO GO TO THE MADNESS
IN NEW YORK.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ CALLED
FOR ALL POLICE FUNDING TO BE
STRIPPED.
HERE IS SOME OF THE WORST
RHETORIC FROM TOP DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE SOME ANSWERING AFTER
ALL OF THIS TODAY.
>> MILITARY EQUIPMENT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT?
THEY DON’T NEED THAT.
THE LAST THING YOU NEED IS AN
ARMORED HUMVEE COMING INTO
A NEIGHBORHOOD.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
PROTECTING THESE PEOPLE.
>> WE CAN REDIRECT SOME OF THE
FUNDING?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
>> [SHOUTING].
WE GET RID OF THAT CANCER.
>> WE HAVE CONFUSED THE IDEA TO
ACHIEVE SAFETY, YOU PUT MORE
COPS ON THE STREET.
>> THE RHETORIC IS UNACCEPTABLE.
THIS IS A WAR ON POLICE AND
A WAR ON INNOCENT TOWNS AND SEES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS RHETORIC NEEDS TO STOP.
THOSE THAT USE IT NEED TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THERE WERE NO SUPPORTIVE
COMMENTS FROM POLICE FROM ANY
TOP DEMOCRATS FOR MONTH.
ONLY WHEN IT SHOWED UP IN THE
POLLS, OH, MAYBE WE WILL TALK
ABOUT IT.
WHEN YEARS WERE POLICE WERE
VILIFIED, YOU WOULD BE HARD
PRESSED TO FIND A SINGLE
DEMOCRAT DEFENDING THE POLICE.
>> [SHOUTING].
PIGS IN A BLANKET.
FRYING LIKE BACON.
>> [SHOUTING].
>> [INAUDIBLE].
WHAT DO WE WANT?
DEAD COPS.
NOW.
>> THAT’S BLM.
POLICE ARE FACING DEMONIZATION
FROM THE LEFT AND FACING A WAVE
OF VIOLENT CRIME IN ALL OF
AMERICA’S DEMOCRAT STATES.
FOR 8 LONG YEARS, BIDEN AND
OBAMA SAIDING IN.
-- SAID NOTHING.
4,000 HOMICIDES IN OBAMA’S
HOMETOWN OF CHICAGO.
THEY DIDN’T LIFT A FINGER TO
HELP THE PEOPLE IN CHICAGO.